foreign
[Music]
let's get this show on the road we are
1700 on the nose
definitely the level of our
opposition has been rising steadily
let's see who we face tonight Anita
bakar
okay E4
and in this speedrun I play
my official opening recommendations we
still have not gotten an accelerated
Dragon this is actually kind of
fascinating how few people play the open
Sicilian and again we're not getting an
accelerated we're getting Knight C3
and every time we Face Knight C3 which
was a couple of times now I sort of
reiterate the explanation of which move
you should play in response and that
depends primarily on what you play
against the open Sicilian so if you're a
knight or a player then you should play
D6 if you're an accelerated Dragon
player which we are for the purposes of
the speedrun then you should play the
move Knight to C6 the point is that if
White NOW plays the move Knight F3 which
she just did
how should we proceed with black well of
course we should basically play with the
understanding that our opponent is going
to play D4 on the next move
so if we're an excited Dragon player
then everything is very easy we play G6
and in the event of D4 which I think is
quite likely we take and then we
transpose directly into an excited
Dragon very nice our first one
okay
Bishop G7 fianchettoing the bishop
and this is our first accelerated dragon
and it makes sense we've hit 1700 this
is
around the time that that we see more
people delve into some of the main lines
alright so
in the accelerated Dragon the the kind
of Zen of this opening is to delay the
move D6 if we play D6 then we allow
white to transpose into the mainline
dragon and there's nothing cardinally
wrong with the dragon itself it's just a
highly theoretical and Incredibly
dangerous opening The Accelerated dragon
essentially does not allow white to
castle queenside without suffering the
consequences so we hold off on the Move
D6 why do we do that well we do that
primarily so that we can play D7 D5 and
open up the center in one Fell Swoop
provided though white allows this to
happen therefore we develop our Knight
first
and if you're seeing this for the first
time you know you might be worried about
the prospect of developing our minor
pieces without first pushing our Pawn
out to D6 but as I'll show you after the
game this is nothing to worry about and
there is a line where white tries to
punish us by trading on C6 and then
playing E5 but in that line black
successfully sacrifices a pawn with the
Knight D5 and gets a very nice
initiative this is a well-known line
according to Theory
three is already a sideline in fact it's
a move that I have never seen before
it's not a very good move
and it's not a very good move because it
doesn't really do anything I mean A3 in
this position is sort of a waste of time
because we are not planning to put
anything on B4
so we can essentially proceed as though
white has given us another turn
and we could probably already get away
with the move D5 but the problem with
playing D5 before castleing is that
after D5 there is the very unpleasant
move Bishop B5 and you can kind of see
why that's annoying white pins the
Knight white threatens Knight takes C6
and then Bishop takes E6 is going to
Fork the king in The Rook so as a
general rule of thumb you only want to
play D5 after you've castled kingside
which is what we're going to do we're
going to Castle kingside we are now
fully ready to push the pawn to D5 and
open up the center and we can really try
to punish white for delaying her
development here Bishop C4 okay now a
very important tactical detail and this
is incredibly common in the accelerated
Dragon it is impossible to play The
Accelerated without knowing this concept
and this is called the center fork trick
and the center fork trick is
ubiquitous across many different
openings and with both colors which
makes it incredibly important to know
and it occurs anytime either side has a
bishop on this square or of course if
you're playing Black you have a bishop
on C5 right this is the precondition for
the center fork trick and what you do is
actually Knight takes E4 anyway
looks like a blunder but if you have a
prior knowledge of this idea you know
that it's not a blunder Knight takes E4
you meet with the move D5 that's where
the fork term comes from and you
essentially re-fork the Knight and the
bishop and you're going to win the piece
back now white can give that piece away
for a pawn but in this particular
version it's not even that easy for
white to win the pawn back as you'll see
so we play the move D5 a couple of
things to notice again mostly if you're
seeing this for the first time
if white plays the move Knight takes
Knight then we take back with the pawn
and even though white has opened up a
line of contact to the D5 Pawn we are
now protecting it with our own B C6 Pawn
so this is an important detail this is
indeed exactly what happens and this is
where white really really pays the price
uh for the move A3 because it is more
common for this position to arise with
white having castled instead of having
played A3 so white keeping the king in
the center and essentially wasting a
move
is is really going to burn them
so what's going on here well we're
attacking the bishop in the night at the
same time hence the fork and the general
kind of prescription for
for responding to the center fork trick
is to keep your Bishop pair
books often recommend this and this is
the best move in a lot of different
openings the move Bishop C4 back to D3
is often the recommended way of
combating the center fork trick and the
point is that after we take the Knight
white takes back the pawn and keeps
their Bishop pair
but if you look a little bit further in
this particular situation the B2 Pawn is
also hanging and it's hanging with Tempo
we take it and we attack The Rook
simultaneously so that's kind of out the
window
that's kind of out the window
and if white stop playing Bishop D3 then
what is y doing well white can probably
take on D5 but then we recapture with
the pawn and again we have the bishop
pair we're attacking the Knight the
Knight can't move back to C3 because
white gets forked again this time on the
fourth rank and if white doesn't move to
C3 then again white loses the B2 Pawn
with tempo
so there's just nothing that white can
do
which comes even remotely close to
equalizing Knight G3 is her choice
okay
well what do we do now well a very bad
move here would be to play Bishop takes
B2 and I think newer players might be
tempted by the look of that move
because you might say well let's grab
that pawn and attack the rook and when
The Rook moves then we can take the
bishop the problem is remember that we
have already sacrificed a piece so
Bishop takes B2 allows white to move the
bishop away from C4 and if we then take
the Rook on A1 white takes back with a
queen and technically black is even up
material in the resulting position
because we have a rook and two pawns for
the two pieces but in most middle game
situations two pieces are preferable to
a rook and you particularly want to
avoid when possible giving away your
fiance Bishop in the accelerated Dragon
unless you absolutely have to or unless
there are some sort of extenuating
circumstances
so Bishop takes B2 would be bad we
simply recapture on C4 now we are up a
pawn okay our opponent gets into an end
game
and of course we will still need to show
a good amount of technique if we want to
finish our opponent off in style here
now C3 is a good move by by our opponent
closing off our Bishop
and now that the Queens are off the
board we need to kind of reassess the
situation we are up a pawn
we have a bishop pair our Bishop on C8
is not yet developed but because the
Queens are off the board our king is not
in any imminent danger it's not like we
need to necessarily rush to get our
Bishop out I think we have bigger fish
to fry here and the particular fish that
I think we should fry is this B2 pawn
and what makes me look at the B2 Pawn
well largely it's the fact that we have
a Pawn on C4 and from some of my endgame
videos you might recognize this as kind
of a deep freeze situation where one of
your pawns is essentially keeping in
place holding down two or more of the
enemy pawns so that pawn on C4 is making
sure that the pawn on B2 is not only a
backward Pawn but has no path forward
that pawn is a huge weakness and it's a
weakness on an open file so there is a
move that's essentially begging to be
played and this is a move we can play
largely without calculation because
there isn't anything to lose by playing
this move
and I'm thinking of the move Rook to B8
now you might say well what about the A7
Pawn well that pawn cannot be captured
because if white would have captured it
we would have taken B2
and then the C3 Pawn very likely would
have also Fallen Rook B1 is just
collapsed by our opponent
The Rook on B1 is unprotected lpdo loose
pieces drop off
and I know this because the Rooks are
not coordinated
and the move that just ends the game
here is Bishop take C3 check
I can sense some people wondering if we
can first play Rook takes B2 and try to
be fancy the answer is no
the answer is no Rook takes B2 Rook
takes B2 Bishop takes C3 check the Rook
can block on D2 it's a common type of
blunder the The Rook that you're forking
can itself block the check and after
takes takes black emerges down a piece
so Bishop C3 is simple and strong now we
have two possibilities we can play
Bishop takes B2 or I think the more
clinical move is to play Rook takes B2
we're already up essentially three pawns
so you should already have one eye on
simplification and trading a pair of
Brooks will make it easier for us as a
consequence to promote the C4 Pawn
so I like the move Rook takes V2
and this is already game over
our first accelerated Dragon experiment
has been a successful one
yeah Bishop takes B2 white is probably
going to take on A7 we're gonna play C3
obviously
and the good thing about C3 is that it
not only prepares to promote the pawn it
also creates an anchor point for our
Rook on D2 and it opens up the A6 F1
diagonal for our light squared Bishop so
we solve all of the problems with that
move
yeah see three we can again at this
point I'm playing largely without
calculation
because there's nothing to calculate
none of our moves contain any risk at
all they're just incredibly
straightforward
and essentially asking to be played yeah
yeah of course we can take A3 there's
nothing inherently wrong with grabbing
another Pawn but we can grab that pawn
now if we wanted to but I'm just trying
to win the game in a more efficient
manner
now here's the order of operations of
course
uh the move that's begging to be played
here is C2 and we're gonna play it
but C2 doesn't actually threaten to
promote what does C2 threaten
so try to figure out what threat does C2
actually pose and we're going to play
this move next against virtually any one
of White's responses
so not Rook D1 immediately because if we
play Rook D1 immediately white takes on
D1
and then perhaps some of you are
attracted to Bishop G4 check but
remember that black and white can block
that with a pawn
instead we need to switch the move order
we want to go Rook D1 but we want to
dislodge the king from E2 first and if
you've been paying attention this move
should occur to Bishop A6 check knock
the King off of E2 then put the Rook on
D1 and the path is now essentially clear
for the pawn to promote we can either
promote immediately and win a piece or
we can try to squeeze a little bit more
out of the situation by deflecting the
bishop off of this diagonal if we can do
that then the promotion comes and we
simply make a new Queen
yeah this is uh
a pretty one-sided game
yeah this has been a very one-sided game
H3 okay so again
if you're playing a Blitz game then
there's nothing wrong with just taking
the rook and then making a queen and
getting up a bishop and a pawn and
converting the resulting position but
we're trying to be as accurate as
possible I'm trying to give you a
glimpse of you know what GM level play
actually looks like and so we're gonna
put into practice an idea that I think
might be a lot less obvious to people
this might be one of the least obvious
ideas of this game
what we're going to do essentially is
use our pawns on the king side to
squeeze the life out of White's minor
pieces the Knight on G3 and the bishop
on E3
first of all this is something everybody
should see are on forkable squares what
could they be forked by well there's
only one thing that could Fork them and
that's a pawn now on what Square would
the pun have to be well the pawn would
have to be on the F4 square but that
seems pretty far-fetched right it seems
like we're not even close to being able
to establish a pawn and F4 and yet
that's an illusion where only three
moves away and we've got all the time in
the world here because white is totally
paralyzed and that's the beauty of you
know of of being able to do what you
want
so we're simply going to start with E5
and then on the next move we're going to
play F5
and the problem isn't only that we will
be threatening F4 we will also be
threatening E4 and that's almost
checkmate
and even if white moves one of the minor
pieces F4 might still be incredibly
effective
so for instance
as we play the move F5 here if white
moves the bishop
seemingly out of sight of the F fund we
will still play F4 and that Bishop on H6
it's contact with C1 is going to be
intercepted that's even better
and white is no squares that's it
resigns
so a simple idea I didn't mean to over
hype it but I think it ends the game a
lot faster than promoting immediately
that one was pretty fast
let's quickly go through some of the
introductory Theory and I'm sure we will
get more accelerated dragon games as we
go along so I'm not going to bog you
down too much in any individual game
so Knight C6
Knight F3 G6 so we transposed into a
main line here Bishop G7 previously we'd
gotten a close Sicilian we'd gotten
Grand Prix attack we'd gotten a good
amount of anti-sicilians okay Bishop B3
of course is the main move now we play
Knight F6 and the sort of introductory
line that I'd like to show here is
Knight takes C6 BC and E5 because this
is a very important line to know
this is a very important line to no no
pull up what I have here
just a moment
yeah so here if you don't know what to
do with black you are likely to kind of
sink under the weight of this E5 Pawn as
far as I know black S2 moves let me
check which one is more popular nowadays
yeah Knight G8 is actually the move I
apologize I what I said during the game
was wrong Knight D5 is not the correct
way to play here even though it's an
interesting Pawn sacrifice but believe
it or not you actually move the Knight
back to G8
now F4 is what most people are going to
play here
and it's important to realize that
despite the sort of appearance
despite appearances Black's position is
completely fine
and white has bitten off more of a chunk
of the center than he can chew black has
a couple of interesting moves here
there's F6 chipping away at the center
immediately but I like the move Knight
H6 redeploying the Knight along the
light squares that white has weakened on
the king side which is a common
byproduct of this particular Pawn chain
the light squares on the king side are
now quite weak
so here the main move is Queen D2
and you can start by castling short
and let's say that White Castle's Queen
side there's still over 100 games in the
database now we have to chip away at
White's Pawn chain with the move D6
now this seems to give up a pawn and it
does but now you've opened up your
Bishop
and the bishop is joined by the Knight
which comes out to F5
but the main drawback of taking on C6 in
any such position is that it opens the B
file and the B file is an absolute Game
Changer in any position with opposite
side castling watch how quickly that
open B file can lead to White's demise
so let's say white plays d e
d e Queen E7
the bishop has to move because it's now
hanging Bishop F2 and already here Rook
B8 is a great move but Rook B8 is not
the best move and this is subtle but
hopefully everybody can understand it
here white can play Bishop C4
and the point of Bishop C4 is to drop
the bishop back to B3 and block the B
file so this move is very tempting but
black is at a bit of a dead end
it's worthwhile to start with the move
Bishop to E6 cover the C4 square and
pre-move Rook B8 when I say pre-move I
mean pre-move even if white plays G4 you
still play Rook AB8 then if white plays
G takes F5
just Queen B4 you don't even need to
sack on B2 you just go Queen B4
B3 and now
Bishop takes C3 is a very bad move
because of Queen to D6 covering the A3
Square you actually want to go Rook B to
d8
forcing the queen away
and if white plays Queen takes the eight
then we play
Queen A3 Chuck
if the king moves up to D2 then we take
the queen
and here we take C3 and Checkmate is
unavoidable on B2
so nothing insane but a pretty nice line
and a good line to know so if we rewind
BC E5 Knight G8 F4 you redeploy the
Knight to H6 this is how quickly white
can go down unless unless white plays a
bunch of computer moves and the
objective assessment of this position is
equal the engine gives zero zero but the
top engine move is something nobody's
gonna play I don't think anybody's gonna
go H3 here I think most people are going
to go Queen D2 the second most popular
move here is Bishop D3
again blacks
continuation is usually reliably the
same you castle and then you play D6 to
try to get rid of that E5 pawn and once
you get rid of it white is left with a
ton of weaknesses black is left with a
semi-open B file and this pawn and F4
sticks out like a sore thumb
actually even stronger is to play Knight
G4 intermediate move
Bishop D2 and the classic Bishop D4 King
H1 Knight F2 check wins in exchange but
this is actually the top engine
suggestion
an important detail here Queen E2 Forks
the bishop and the pawn but the bishop
can drop back to C5 x-ray defending E7
and black is fine here black is much
better actually open Exchange
so anyways
that's another way for white to be worse
after Knight G8 white can also try the
move Bishop to D4 which is almost as
popular as F4
and here you have to know the move Queen
to A5 get the queen out
and there is a very important line where
white plays the move E6 and again if you
don't know the theory it's easy to get
overwhelmed here
because you can't take the pawn because
you dropped the bishop and a mistake
would be to take the bishop allowing
white to get the queen into D4 and hit
the rook in the corner so instead all
you have to do here is get the night out
to F6 Knight F6 and black is better
and black is better because even though
the king gets out to F7 it's perfectly
safe here and black has a massive Pawn
Center
Bishop C4 check is met with D5
and if Bishop B3
then black has an incredibly strong move
here which is a direct product of white
delaying the castling who can spot this
move
kind of a classic idea
yeah it's E5 it's it's E5 this is an
important move to have in your sort of
toolkit
and if white takes on E5 some 2200s
2300s have played like this Rook E8
white has to play F4
and now I like the top engine move
Knight G4 is great
also good is the move Queen to B6 to
prevent white from castling
and if Queen F3 you prevent white from
Castle link Queen Side by playing this
mysterious looking move Bishop to H6
but it's not mysterious if you consider
what how you prevent castling now you
can take E5 the pawn on F4 is pinned so
you've prevented white from castling
either side and now the king is stuck in
the center where it is going to be
massacred by a combination of forces
Knight G4 Bishop A6 is going to be very
strong this is like minus plus and
White's pieces are biting on granite on
D5
and that's another nice line
if white takes the other way e takes D7
well then white black plays Bishop takes
D7 check
and for example if white plays Bishop to
C4
very strong here is the move Bishop to
G4
with the idea of meeting F3 another
trick with Rook to d8
and if fg4 C5 and you're going to lose
the bishop on D4 and Black's gonna get a
devastating initiative here just
devastating
one thing you should never be afraid of
in these types of positions is moving
your king it's okay to move your king
because White's getting crushed in the
center
Castle's CD and white loses a minor
piece because if the Knight moves you
lose the bishop otherwise black takes
the Knight The Rook on d8 is protected
so this is you know a short overview of
what to do after Knight takes C6 and E5
which you're definitely going to face if
you play The Accelerated Dragon for any
length of time
all right so in the game our opponent
plays this move A3 which is obviously
a a very strange move it's not a very
good move I see that it has been played
a fair number of times
but I think Bishop C4 is a follow-up
mistake after which white is simply in
huge trouble
I mean white should probably go Bishop
E2 to avoid the center fork trick but
even here
um black I think should just go D5
and black is definitely slightly better
I mean white has literally just wasted a
move for no reason
I see that seven games continued 85
Knight D5
Knight C6 BC and you should never be
afraid of this Pawn structure in the
accelerated Dragon because it's
compensated by the tremendous activity
of your pieces if you look at the Knight
and your Bishop they're both aiming at
the Knight on C3
white is in trouble here
if Bishop D4 then you can play Knight
takes C3 and white is forced to ruin
their Pawn structure
for example Bishop C3 now you trade now
you get your queen to A5
and the attack on C3 is very powerful
The Rook is coming to d8 this is again
minus over plus is the evaluation here
so everywhere you look black is already
better here but Bishop C4 exacerbates
the situation because of Knight takes E4
and or I wouldn't call say that the game
is over but it's definitely
borderline lost for white perhaps white
should play Bishop takes F7 check
and you should remember that when you
face the center fork trick
the recommendation is usually to do what
our opponent did or no not to do what
our opponent did the recommendation when
you're facing the center fork trick in
most openings is to keep your Bishop
pair with a move Bishop to D3 so for
instance for instance let me take
another opening where the center fork
trick is common
let's take a very primitive example so
in the four nights if you play Bishop C4
black has the move Knight takes E4
and here after Knight takes C4 D5
the only way for white to not be worse
is to play this move Bishop to D3
and black has to recapture and then
white is able to preserve the bishop
pair and white is doing okay here the
position is equal okay
I can show you in the perk right in the
perk there is a there's a line
where
essentially here here
whatever Bishop C4
Castle's castles here black can take on
e4 and again in this position the best
move for white is Bishop to D3
d e Bishop E4 and white is considered a
little bit better in this line
but if we compare this to the position
we had in our game white essentially
cannot do the same thing because if
white plays Bishop D3 here then we
actually can take the other Knight and
we're just a pawn up
and if white takes first and then plays
Bishop D3 which might have been the
Lesser evil this might have been the
best that white can do but here in
addition to taking this Pawn after which
white is much worse the engine actually
recommends the devilish move Bishop to
A6 preventing white from castling and
keeping the king confined in the center
and if white takes Bishop C6 now we play
Bishop B2
and if white takes the Rook we give a
nice little check on A5 and look at this
line if Queen D2 Bishop C3 wins the
queen
if Bishop D2 the queen swings to E5 then
the bishop drops back to C3 and again
white loses the queen in all of his
other pieces
so this is the power of preventing your
opponent from castling when you yourself
are castled and in Total Safety
so anyways
this is why Bishop D3 is not possible
here
now our opponent's Choice definitely
made things worse for her I think
probably white should just Castle here
probably why it should just Castle here
and after DC I mean at least White's
king is not unsafe of course we're still
up upon we still have an attack on B2
it's minus plus but of course the game
continues so sometimes you just gotta
castle out of it white went into this
end game but as it turns out this end
game is just totally lost because the
attack on B2 is completely Unstoppable I
mean white probably has to play this
move to Stave off immediate defeat but
we're not even going to talk about this
black is up a pawn here and white is
completely paralyzed and you could even
carry out a similar idea to what we did
in the game you could play like F5 and
then E5 and creep up with your Pawns in
the center and white is just totally out
of squares
so this is this is awful okay rugby one
Bishop takes E3 the game is over
immediately and we don't have to talk
about the rest
so
pretty one-sided but a good introduction
to The Accelerated dragon as you can see
even at this level a lot of players feel
very very lost on the white side of the
excited because it's not the most common
Sicilian and it's not that often taught
and uh hopefully this gave you a good
illustration of some some of the
introductory lines especially we talked
about Knight takes C6 at length but the
key thing to remember is you're not
afraid to bring the Knight back to G8
and don't be afraid to analyze this with
an engine on your own as well
the main line by the way the main line
here is Bishop C4 castles and then
Bishop back to B3 why does white need
Bishop B3 well you already know the
reason for that here black again has the
center fork trick with Knight E4 and by
contrast to the game continuation this
is a better version for for white and
here white can in fact Play Bishop D3
and reach this position but it is
considered that black is even slightly
better after Queen C7 because you get
the semi-open B file you get the D file
and the accelerated Bishop on G7 is just
super super strong here
but hopefully I will even make marozzi's
kind of interesting all right
let's
get in another game unless there are any
questions this was a very
straightforward one but you know I can't
control how our opponents play we can
only control how we play
all right
hope you enjoyed the speed run bye
[Music]